[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and i
know your feeds are probably full of ios
7 stuff today but some lighter stuff uh
cyanogenmod for those of you who don't
know is a rom built on top of android
that essentially adds a ton of features
and customization that the stock version
of android doesn't have so custom pull
downs and toggles and shortcuts and
themes and a ton more system settings
that all enhance android and there are a
ton of other roms that do this too
cyanogenmod is just one of them but i
happen to use cyanogenmod as basically
my go-to rom for anytime i want to put a
device as close to stock android as
possible where if i don't like the skin
so i did this with my super nexus
project i've done this in tons of videos
in the past i don't like touchwiz i
don't like htc sense whenever i want to
put a device closer to stock android my
first bet is usually cyanogenmod now
these guys have always been ahead of the
curve in terms of development like they
recently made that awesome camera app
called focal if you guys haven't heard
of it that's pretty awesome too but
recently they've shifted gears and just
started churning out a ton of awesome
stuff in addition to cyanogenmod and
that's kind of the way cyan jumps always
been if you look back pretty much all of
the newest features in each new version
of android you can probably guarantee
half of them showed up somewhere in a
rom for a rooted version of android like
cyanogenmod but there are always quirks
with cyanshimod and every rom has had
the same problem the installation
process is a nightmare if you ever ask
someone why they haven't installed
cyanogenmod or why they haven't
installed aokp or some other rom on
their device it's because they're either
scared of the routing process or it's
too complicated or there's too many
steps or there's too many risks for
failure and it's just not practical for
people so today cyanogenmod has decided
to take the full next step forward to go
fully mainstream so cyanogenmod went out
and raised seven million dollars to
build a better version of android so
they plan to do android better than
google itself now a lot of the headlines
have sort of misconstrued the facts and
made it seem like they're building their
own separate operating system to compete
against android that's not exactly true
in fact that's not true at all
essentially they're keeping a lot of
google code and they're using android as
the sort of foundation for this new
experience but then they're going to be
branching out and adding like i said a
ton of new things that they do best
and making a totally brand new
experience so this may feel very
different from android when you use it
but it's built on top of an android
foundation now the goal they have for
this is still really close to a sort of
competitive nature it's market share
they want to be the number three spot in
terms of market share behind the
traditional android and ios and you'd be
surprised how close they are to actually
doing that right now see android with
its incredibly convoluted and difficult
installation process still has 8 million
users who have been registered that
means there are 8 million users who have
ticked the box that says i want to send
my information off to cyanogen when i
install this most people don't tick that
box and they estimate there's somewhere
between 15 and 25 million signage and
mod users who have gone through that
hectic process and rooted their device
just to install it so windows phone has
the backing of microsoft and their
billions of dollars of revenue and they
just keep pumping money into windows
phone and it's not growing nearly as
quickly as cyanogenmod is so cyanogen is
really close to already being in the
number three spot way ahead of
blackberry way ahead of the other fringe
sort of operating systems like firefox
os and ubuntu phone os this has a really
good shot speaking of funding
seven million dollars is a lot of money
for a software project like this for
development and if you were an investor
investing seven million confident
dollars into something you would expect
to get your seven million dollars back
out of your investment in the near
future but if you check out the blog
post that details everything it'll be
below that like button essentially what
they've said is that finances are not a
primary concern so don't expect to see
ads in cyanogenmod anytime soon if
that's what you guys are thinking but
the funny thing is i think this is a
project that is going to take off
because of one main underrated reason
and a lot of people have skimmed over it
but it's pretty important it's the new
installer like i mentioned earlier
installing cyanogenmod on most devices
today or even any roms is a nightmare
right now if the average person wants to
install cyanogenmod on say their galaxy
s4 they have to unlock the bootloader if
it's locked and they have to figure out
if it's locked or not that takes some
steps then you have to root the device
that takes some steps you have to wipe
it flash the cache get it completely
clean then install it install cyan
engine mod and the g apps and all this
stuff is just there's so many places to
fail there's so many ways it can go
wrong that people just don't want to go
through and that hassle is completely
wiped out with the proposed new cyan
engine mod installer which looks to have
a clean simple user interface to get
regular people to be able to install
this now like i said there is about
eight million registered cyanogenmod
users out there i think that number will
blow up when the average person gets the
opportunity to install a brand new
awesome experience on their device
without a whole ton of hectic steps if
they do this right this will be a key
feature of the new cyan engine mod the
new installer for getting cyan engine
mod installed on your device will be the
number one feature in the new
cyanogenmod but what's funny is the most
impressive thing to me and what's not
even announced yet is that cyanogen has
a hardware partner an unannounced
hardware partner they're going to be
announcing in the next couple of weeks
for this new project
like that that's really legit because
once you get a hardware partner and a
new software project going together side
by side working with each other that is
really really important most people will
never get that sort of support my
fingers are crossed that it's a
manufacturer that we already know has a
reputation for a high quality hardware
so i'm thinking htc oppo you guys you
guys have a pretty good idea of what you
would probably want to say and you can
leave that in a comment below but uh i
think that can have some massive
potential for the 2014 competition when
we see a whole bunch more devices
released and you know we'll see android
stuff ios stuff and cyanogenmod stuff so
at the end of the day what does this
mean for google and for cyanogen for
google not that much i mean the number
one thing they're probably concerned
about here is licensing and we've seen a
lot of information actually uh posted by
the people who are working on this about
licensing and how they plan to work on
that and get that sorted out so that
shouldn't be too much of an issue and
then for cyanogen it's just all hard
work from here on out i have my fingers
crossed that this works i wish them the
best of luck it's a super ambitious
project but if it's successful it's
going to be a game changer i have no
doubts that next year is going to be
very different if this goes according to
plan and one last thing i highly suggest
reading through the cyanogenmod ama it's
on the first page of reddit right now as
i speak and a lot of the answers in that
ama have not even been published
anywhere else yet so there's a lot of
information some cool stuff that i
haven't talked about like the
cyanogenmod account where you basically
get to sync device settings from device
to device with cyanogenmod on it some
cool unannounced stuff in there so you
should check that out that'll be the
first link below that like button so if
you want to read through all the answers
that'll be there and uh that's it i'll
head out of here thank you for watching
and uh if you want to subscribe to see
more videos like this there's more
upcoming including a review of this
device but that's just a sneak peek
and uh kush if you're watching this
htc
htc
thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
you